alors j'ai rencontré là depuis tout
petit je dirais et avant quand j'ai
acheté mes bijoux
je trouvais que c'était ça manquait
quelque chose il fallait que j'apporte
ma touche finale parce que je suis
quelqu'un qui aime tout ce qui brille
qui aiment tout ce qui sort de
l'ordinaire
c'est comme ça que vous avez commencé à
travailler ou vous souvenez de votre
première création
oui je me rappelle très bien c'est une
petite bague j'avais acheté de rien du
tout et je trouvais ce n'était pas joli
et à ce moment là je commence à imaginer
comment que je pouvais retransformer
cette petite bague effectivement j'ai
les fuit depuis je suis dans la création
mais vraiment à fond effectivement par
rapport à mes créations par rapport à
tout ce que j'ai dégagé à la délégation
de miss martinique avait fait appel à
moi en 2015
j'avais fabriqué l'akron de mme hogan
edvige qui est sentie première dauphine
miss france
vous avez aussi fabriqué dernièrement
lors du carnaval la couronne de patricia
effectivement il ya une bonne copine à
moi qu'à faire appel à moi qu elle sait
qu est-ce que j'ai des gages en tant que
créatrice elle à faire appel à moi pour
me dire mais valve je vais te mettre sur
un projet est ce que vous allez pouvoir
tenir j'ai dit oui pourquoi pas parce
que je me connais et effectivement mais
le résultat est là tout le monde est
content mon poids des petits messages ça
me fait grand plaisir